oh my counter didn't get lower I'm just
wearing high-waisted pants no are we at
all on a slant just a general question
this is what it's like to make videos by
yourself hi my name is different now
time for another hellofresh I make one
of their meals and we see what happens
situations very hungry so I thought now
in this fragile emotional state of
starvation it might be the best time to
film a hellofresh video you a so the
hellofresh supports me once a month and
here we got like a period they're here
and we're purposeful I only had a couple
talking points out but like I gotta I'm
gonna do some breathing exercises hold
up hello fresh makes cooking thanks they
make cooking they make they discovered
cooking hello fresh makes making meals
in your kitchen a reality regardless of
your comfort in your own kitchen look
how comfortable I am in my kitchen okay
sorry I'm sorry
I also might have shot two other videos
today and it might be a long day so this
is gonna be a silly one oh did you know
I bet you didn't that hellofresh has
more what hello fresh has more five-star
recipes than any other meal kit so you
know you're gonna get something
delicious couple of fresh is a
subscription meal service that delivers
you all of these meals with all the
ingredients nothing more than what you
need to make the meal so you feel like
you're like capable you can easily
change your delivery date or your food
preferences depending on like what
changes in your life you're not stuck
with one specific thing there had an
open relationship with hellofresh
I'm making salmon I have never actually
cooked salmon and I can remember salmon
and couscous oh and I am king excited
about it I was some Mary Poppins right
there right
no eggs so everything fella fresh comes
in a bag you can't shut up unless you do
it up which sometimes I do which is why
we have this built-in drinking game
which makes this kind of video so much
more fun and interactive for all of us
there are six steps on your recipe car
they have word steps and picture steps
you get it I'm not great at this so I
will inevitably back up so right now
write down a piece of paper
tell yourself in your head say it out
loud to your pet your friend to the
stranger at the gas station just commit
to yourself which step you think I'm
gonna ultimately shop and then that's
where you drink the alternative is drink
every time I do something correct it's
like cooking make it your own here we go
I'm a little drunk off of that shot
which gives me nothing but power hello I
feel like this is the first round of
chopped there we go I can handle this I
get you I get you no I get you
my boyfriend's out of town and you just
show up like this wash and dry all
produce the only things I have to wash
and dry great Wow thinly sliced scallion
separating the greens from the whites
love scallions because it's literally
like when I let my hair air dry I guess
those are White's those are green I said
tomatoes hey guys know if I'm old or
stupid okay we've officially finished
step 1 know what that means the drinking
game has no rules and everyone's rules
at the right rule step 2 we're gonna
cook our couscous about 1 tablespoon of
butter in a medium pot over medium-high
heat and couscous and cook stirring
occasionally until lightly toasted 2 to
3 minutes or in 3/4 cup of water at
stock concentrate bring to a boil then
cover and reduce to a low simmer cooking
top dente 6 to 8 minutes cover pot and
set aside I know some of you get very
upset when I leave cabinet doors
refrigerators or anything open don't
worry I take that into consideration I
am keeping all of my drawers doors and
emotions completely closed we're done
step number 2 and I don't want to alarm
you what
you've a tiny cup near you Cheers step
three when I cook the salmon rinse the
salmon why do we have to rinse you so
soon
rinsing this fish sounds like like me
telling anyone that I wash my vagina oh
I got too drunk cuz I don't want to have
to go into the video oh I spilled some
scum
it's a hit happen cause there's so many
bleep gross good job you giant clitoris
we Susan Oliver assault and Italian
seasoning oh wait early making it up the
pan one tablespoon butter and 1
tablespoon olive oil and now I have to
go back to seasoning the salmon with
Italian seasoning we're gonna put it in
the pan inside down until it gets crispy
brown and crispy we're washing our hands
we're back we're back that beeping means
salmon eats we flip everything's great
the salmon looks great maybe I don't
know you don't taste it so you're fine
okay definitely we're on the step 4
which means who [ __ ] knows so step
four is meanwhile make a salad to shave
the zucchini then we have to zest and
half the lemon don't you whip me the
Internet's gonna be so jealous of how
cool we made this meal ya know we have
to make ribbons out of this all right
let's try on this if this peeler has
been sold to me as if this thing in the
middle can do ribbons outside of just
these two things then I want to make
sure that I got my money's worth
it's just shred now this this okay this
seems like the right call is phallic and
best and half the lemon I met this woman
prematurely lemon it's okay it happens
to a lot of lemons got half the lemon in
let's zest it we have to combine our
green scallions in this bowl and then
all of our tomato and then we need to
add a drizzle of olive oil and we'll
season was sown better I'm stirring it
with a potato peeler because
and just I'm hungry which takes us to
step number five which as you know means
whatever the actual you want here we go
preserve a quarter teaspoon lemon zest
love couscous with a fork then stir in
scallion whites and remaining lemon zest
season with salt and pepper oh my god
would make the crema in a small bowl
goodbye and sour cream is going to fully
hurt me but you know what I do it for
you guys cuz I'm in the comfort of my
own home I have a couple crevices that I
can repent my sins into sour cream and
lemon zest salt and pepper add 1tsp of
water at a time until the mixture
reaches a drizzling consistency that's
delicious holy good this is so [ __ ]
good so if you want sorry okay guys
don't know excuse me
I want to keep eating all right if you
want any piece of fish go to hell fresh
calm and use the promo code grace Helbig
ate $50 off first month I don't know
what you have to lose yeah a little
drunk yeah this is delicious and yeah
hello fresh is now for five dollars and
sixty six cents per serving and yeah
somehow they keep supporting me because
this is the most fun thing ever this is
so delicious I don't mean to quote
as its beers that like oops I don't know
if you're dating someone and you want to
impress them yeah you go already in a
relationship with someone and you want
to have like a situation in which you
don't have to like do pottery like the
ghost thing but you can also work
together here you go
oh okay it's warranted I get it I get it
all right we're done hey girls